two
one and you're live chairman good
evening and welcome to the southeast
area planning committee meeting on
wednesday the 28th of october 2020.
my name is councillor m w helm and i'm
vice chairman deputising for richard
juric
the chairman this meeting is being held
under new regulations which came into
effect on the 4th of april in response
to the covid 19 panic
tandemic just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all pleased to ask everyone
present in this meeting
to ensure your microphone is muted and
your video feed is off
when not addressing the committee this
will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbance
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and being by present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat
function of the meeting to indicate if
you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time members are reminded
that apart from indicating you wish to
speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function
should not be used for questions or any
other purpose
members when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers please reference a
page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone and video
now may ask officers taking part in the
meeting to introduce themselves starting
with mr lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
and i am lead specialist place and chief
plan officer at oregon district council
thank you
michael johnson good afternoon chairman
my name is michael johnson i'm lead
specialist development management
thank you thank you annie keane
she's not present tonight okay louise
staples
hello i'm louise staplehurst and i'm a
specialist in development management
thank you bernard uh good afternoon
members bender casey clark to the
committee
thank you thank you for any other
offices present
uh no chairman right berna can i ask you
to carry out a roll call
of members to confirm whose intentions
please
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order please
indicate
that your attendance um i'll start with
councillor bassinger
good evening everyone i'm present thank
you councillor beal
good evening everyone ryan bill speaking
i am present council bell
good evening everybody i'm present
cancer boyce
present thank you councilman mr channel
oh good evening burner good evening
chairman and everyone
i am present thank you very much cancer
helm
i think i'm present thank you
good evening
can you hear me thank you cancer
chairman can i now ask members in
attendance to please introduce
themselves now
good evening councillor bamford in
attendance benner
thank you council bamford good evening
and welcome
welcome and that's sorry that's
councillor morris
that is thank you thank you anybody else
in attendance i think i saw somebody
else popping up there
oh cancer customers
yeah yes council council amazed lovely
thank you very much chairman
um i have apologies for absence please
berna
yes chairman we've received apologies
for absence from councillors dueck
at schemes and stamp thank you
thank you very much uh minutes is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 30th of september
2020 found on pages 7 to 10 are approved
as a syrian
record iso move if you wish to second
that motion
please turn on your video and move your
microphone and state your name now
please
secondary chairman councillor penny
channel thank you
uh does anyone wish to raise any items
in that
are we uh gonna agree that by a cent
happy to agree by sent chairman
agreed declaration uh declaration of
interest disclose the existence and
nature of any disputable pecuniary
interest
or other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to isis
business on the agenda
having regards to paragraph six to eight
inclusive the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
needs arise throughout the meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the chat function to indicate
now and i'll invite you to speak
counselor channel chairman chancellor
channel
thank you thank you very much chairman
just to declare a non-pursuing interest
in that i'm also a member of essex
county council
who are consulted on any matters within
their remit
i.e highways access education
and any other matters chairman but
mostly tonight's i think uh
will apply well not not sure totally
which
both of them so i'll just leave it like
that during my declaration
anybody else no no chairman
um we all need to
declare an interest sorry german yeah
sorry tim uh i think councillor hull
would like to
i think we're going to the same with um
thank you uh we now
move on to item five uh application
twenty
double o seven double three full
lander james jason orchard house
neptune's chase mayland
[Music]
found on pages 11-22 please note that a
member's update in relation to this
application
has also been circulated prior to the
meeting
in a moment i will call on officers to
present this item
remember as a reminder if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known
using the check function within the miss
meeting i will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
concise miss staplehurst please
uh apologies chairman for the further
interruption could i check if councillor
bassinger wishes to make a declaration
because he has his
hand up just before we move into the
actual presentation
that's the passenger yeah no i'm sorry i
wasn't aware my hand is up are you sure
that's me
yes yes okay this is yeah
it is let's see if i can remove it there
we are is that down
yes yeah i'm sorry sorry no it's still
up
sorry i'll take it down okay
that's lovely now okay thank you very
much thank you very much
thank you chairman
planning permission is sought for an
equestrian arena to ride horses in the
winter months
and please note as said previously and
the members update which has the
environmental health response
and also an amendment to condition four
to reflect boundary treatment details
that have been
um sent in since the report was written
showing a timber post and rail fence
will be used
surrounding the arena
this is the location plan and you can
see
the whole site outlined in red here
and the development would lie to the
north in this part here
and planning permission has already been
granted for a stable in this location
here
and the equestrian arena will be used in
relation to this and the equestrian use
of the whole site
you can see more clearly here the
positioning of the arena to the north of
the site
and the stable building which has
already been approved
some examples of the materials to be
used and what the arena will look like
when it's finished
particularly this one showing the
fencing materials and the sand mix
these are some photos of the site a view
to the north where the development will
be located
a view of the access leading west from
nipsor's chase
and another photo towards the north of
the site
the proposal is considered to be
acceptable subject to the conditions set
out in section 8 of the report
with also the amendment to condition for
boundary treatments as set out within
the members updates
and the informatives also requested by
environmental health
thank you chairman thank you mr hurst in
line with public
participation scheme i now invite the
applicant
mr canny kenny patton to read out their
submission my reminds you that
you are only allowed two minutes to
speak in accordance with the scheme
mr patton okay
thank you for allowing me to speak at
this meeting today
as i'm sure many of you are aware my
wife loves horses
unfortunately we live on essex claim
which becomes
very wet in the winter and this riding
arena will allow my wife
and our young nieces to ride on an
all-weather surface
throughout the year this will reduce
their reliance on riding on the roads in
the wet winter months
which will be much safer particularly as
one of our nieces
is disabled and attends the riding for
the disabled charity
we have clarified that the boundary
treatment is to be timber post and real
fencing
so we hope that this will mean no need
for condition four
the riding arena is located behind the
stable building
so will not be seen from the road and we
intend
to plant a hornbeam hedge on the
boundaries
we have already submitted a drainage
plan
this riding arena is only for the use of
our family
and i very much hope that you can all
support this application
and agree with the officer's
recommendation to approve
thank you thank you very much mr patton
um would officers like to comment before
moving on to the recommendation
the recommendation is set up within the
report is as follows
that planning application 2007 double
three fuel
land adjacent orchard house nips has
chased mainland
be approved such that the conditions as
detailed in section 80 through support
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
i'll move your microphone and state your
name now
chairman i'm happy to second that
counselor penny chenna
thank you very much thank you i now
invite members to make any comments on
the report
burner who has indicated they wish to
speak please
anybody wish to speak all right yes sir
yeah thank you very much chairman um
well chairman obviously i've
i've seconded so i'm happy with the
proposal to approve but i just wanted to
raise that mainland parish council
has sent a lettering of representation
and they
obviously have a view that it should be
refused because of their drainage issues
but i note the officer's response on the
order paper
and therefore can the officer confirm to
me that
bearing in mind the condition applied
that everything
is satisfactory in that and there's no
reason at all
for the mainland parish council issue of
refusal to actually be considered
because
it is perfectly covered by what's been
submitted and the conditions you've
applied
yes i can clarify that they did submit a
surface water drainage report it came in
um a few weeks after the application was
made valid
so it wouldn't have been um visible for
the parish council to see when they were
first consulted
uh but environmental health have been
consulted on that report and are happy
that
um all the drainage is sufficient and
there is a condition included to make
sure it's carried out in accordance with
those details
thank you chairman thank you very much
any other member please
no chairman right
now move to the vote do you want to take
a vote or do you want to do this by cent
we need to vote on this as all right
vote then please
do you want a recorded vote or just a
general vote recorded then please
bernard would you take the roll call
please
thank you members this is just a normal
vote um
i'll take you in alphabetical order can
you stay clearly for
against or abstain counselor bassinger
four that's the beale ball
council bell four
boys four
did you say chana paul yes you said my
name sorry
cancer helm or castle hall
four members that's
seven for the recommendation none
against and no abstentions
thank you chairman thank you very much
members we now move on to item six
thank you everyone
thank you mr patton we now
move on to item six twenty double o
eight double three house beechcrest sea
view
parade st lawrence essex
found on pages 22 to 32
please note that the members update in
relation to the application has been
circulated prior to the
the meeting in a moment i will call on
the officer to bring this item members a
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item
please make this known using the chat
function within the meeting
i will then come to you in turn to keep
your points clear and succulent ms
keenan please print the
report please
planning permission is sought for the
erection of a
of a single story ground floor extension
and a first floor front and rear
extension
including a gamble style front dormer
and a flat roof
side dormer further alterations also
include an extension to the roof terrace
at first floor level
and cedar cladding to the whole dwelling
as stated please see the members update
with additional public comments and
comments from the agent
this is the location plan showing the
site here outlined in red
is the proposed block plan and you can
see the
um this is the front where the gamble
style dormer would be
and the extension to the roof terrace
and then
the additional extensions to the side
here
this is the existing northern elevation
existing western elevation
southern elevation and the existing
eastern elevation
this is the proposed northern elevation
showing the
gamble style front dormer which will be
out of keeping and unbalance
the relationship with this neighbor here
and you can also see the extension to
the roof terrace here
is the proposed western elevation
showing the flat roof side dormer
and the rear extension this is the
proposed
southern elevation showing the
alterations to the existing rear
conservatory
to form a more solid structure
and the proposed rear projection which
would extend from the existing southern
elevation
to bring the rear projection in line
with the southern elevation of the
dwelling
this is the proposed eastern elevation
showing the
proposed gamble style roof projecting
forward
of the um front elevation of the
neighbor
are the existing ground floor plans
and the existing first floor plans
the proposed ground floor plans
and the proposed first floor plans
this is the existing and proposed
streets street scene elevations
showing the proposed alteration in
relation to the adjoining
neighbor here and neighbouring dwellings
either side
this application follows a previously
refused application
uh which was refused due to the scale
bulk and design of the development
which was considered to appear dominant
in relation to the pair of semi-detached
dwellings
however and those are the um
previously refused at uh side elevations
as well
and this was a recently approved
application uh which was approved
last week uh which is considered to be
much more in keeping with the character
and appearance
of the area and the dwelling and
especially in keeping with this neighbor
as well
the flat roof front and side dormers
take cues from the neighboring dwelling
and the front
and whilst the front dormer is larger
than the than the neighboring dormers
it doesn't detrimentally impact upon the
character and appearance of the host
dwelling
or the pair of dwellings
and the other elevations from the
approved application
and then just showing the street scene
plan of the approved application
and how it's much more in keeping with
the attached neighbouring dwelling
here are some photos of the site so this
is the application site
and some photos of the street scene it's
noted that there are dwellings of
differing styles within the street scene
but unlike the application site these
dwellings are detached and
form their own character the application
is recommended for refusal due to the
proposed gamble style
design of the first floor front
extension which should be out of keeping
and unbalance
the pair of semi-detached dwellings
thank you chairman
thank you mr staplehurst um in line with
public participation scheme i now
invite the agent mr terry hyland to read
out their submissions
may i remind you that you are allocated
two minutes only
for the public speaking in accordance
with the scheme
mr hyland please call his camera as well
if possible
hello you've got two minutes sir hello
can anyone hear me
yes yes good evening everyone thanks for
uh letting me speak um yes um
straight into things um having given
consent to the flat roof dormer scheme
appears that only the objection is to
the formation of the gambral dormer in
lieu of the flat roof option
appended to my report which hopefully
councillors have all received was a
document called planning
timeline that provides relevant history
of the development has occurred adjacent
to the applicant's property during their
long-term occupation of their dwelling
putting aside changes in the lda plan
within this time just felt that this
history is very relevant when
considering this application
as i've endured considerable adjacent
significant development in the
intervening years
some possibly unauthorized in summary
these developments that have taken place
completely contradict the proposed
reason for refusal for this particular
application
alterations to the immediately adjoining
property may have unreasonably
influenced and this application given
that their first floor window was
changed to french door with doors very
recently
again please refer to that uh planning
timeline
i won't read out the um officer's
proposal as a refuge was there for
everyone to
see but illustrations have been made to
demonstrate the erroneous issue of
so-called
unbalanced appearance this pair of
properties apart from the profile of the
very original footprint
has not appeared visually balanced since
before 2010 at the very least
also this principle historically has not
been adhered to on adjacent properties
as again has demonstrated an appended
document planning
timeline design is completely subjective
despite
architectural references to established
principles those involve this
application
have researched and worked very hard
with all the interested parties
to produce a high quality design
appropriate to a setting particularly
the give
given the infinite variety of properties
in lawrence by
overlooking the river it is vehemently
contested that this design is out of
keeping given that it references both
the host dwelling
and the roof of the property water's
edge immediately westwards
thank you uh does any officer want to
speak before i move the recommendation
no chairman right the recommendation is
set with the report is as follows
that planning application 2008 double
three house speak press see view
promenades at lawrence essex
be refused for the reasons as detailed
in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
i'll mute your micro and state your name
now please
nobody right i'll move on to uh any
members that would like to uh chairman
i'll second that
who's that oh crouch the voice yeah
accepted by councillor boyce
all right if any members wish um uh
and uh now invite members to make any
comments on this report please
berna who's indicated to speak please
counselor bash
messenger chairman casper passenger
thank you mr chairman um i would just
like to say that i actually think this
is uh quite an attractive development to
be honest
um we're often told that you know
planning
and visuals are very subjective but when
you actually look at what's there and
what's proposed
personally i think this is a good thing
this is
this is development in a good way i
can't see how those
those two buildings are visually
you know it's important that they look
the same they i don't really get that
i can see that there are two buildings
that really would benefit from being
upgraded
one of them i think is a perfectly
decent looking upgrade
considering the area has many many
developments with
balconies french doors and whatnot so
personally i think we should approve
this application
thank you is that proposal council
passenger
that is a proposal thank you very much
i'd like to propose
that we approve this application okay
okay would you like to speak as a ward
member then please
counseling i would indeed chairman i did
ask to speak actually
um earlier but never mind it appears
mine came down and i
i said that was the ward member i have
actually called this in chairman
this application as you can see from the
order paper
uh councillor bassinger has said a lot
of what i was going to say and the agent
also i mean
the only thing that i can see that is
fundamentally different to a degree but
very small is the gamble roof i think
we've seen what's already been approved
under the earlier application the
officer highlighted to us
i've actually walked the whole area
today i walked along the sea wall and
studied the
houses which i knew anyway but i went to
refresh my mind
clearly the street scene is very very
different and i noticed the report even
talks about the local area well i'm
sorry i don't think we can consider the
local area at all
because the local area is very much the
same as sea view promenade
a multitude of different designs and
different things various balconies here
they're everywhere different sizes of
windows different heights
in fact to the east of the property i
think i'm getting it right is virtually
what i would call
a three-story contemporary premises then
the neighbor the other side
um is different again to the two
semi-detached in fact we have um and i'm
not sure chairman can i have it
confirmed i believe one of the neighbors
sent in a letter of support
and i couldn't see that on the um
initial report
and i just want to check that all
members might be aware of that that
actually one of the neighbors
um has offered support to this
development yes
so chairman um can we just see this
gamble roof that appears to be causing
the problem and i think it might be
looking from
the west direction the officer showed it
so i'd be very grateful
um if we could see that chairman yes
yes now can i see it from the um
what do you call that's the north
elevation can i see from the west
right and now from the east please
right sherman well there we go that is
what we're looking at
and to be honest um i really do not have
an issue with that there's not a great
deal of projection
past the joining semi detached um
to me it's minimal in terms of that and
i think actually it's more attractive
than what the officers have approved
under the
the uh recent application zero zero
eight two seven
so chairman our councillor bassinger has
moved the proposal i'm very happy to
second that chairman
uh for the reasons i've given and
bearing in mind
the immense different degrees of design
down
sea view promenade the different types
of buildings i don't think we should
just center ourselves on looking at two
semi-detached buildings here
we need to consider the whole area and
actually i would see this as an
improvement i've been there today and no
disrespect to the area or anything
i would think this design if
incorporated if approved tonight
would actually bring benefits and look
much better
with all due respect to what is there
currently chairman that is my opinion
and i'm happy to second that proposal
thank you very much i'm also the award
member and i agree entirely with
councillor chana
um regarding does anyone else want to
speak
nobody's indicated chairman right
councillor boyce
you second the the recommendation are
you prepared to carry on with that or do
you want to
oh yes of course i support the officer's
recommendation okay
we'll move to the recommendation first
because that was first on the list
um berna can you take a vote please
thank you chairman members um i will
call your name in
alphabetical order this is for the
office's recommendation of
of refusal can you state clearly for
against or abstain
counselor passenger against
the deal against the bell
against
against thank you members
that's one for the recommendation
and six against members thank you
we move now to i could see some hands
waving about there
we moved now to councillor passengers
proposal
would you like to repeat that please
council bastion which is seconded by
councillor channel uh my proposal is to
actually approve this
application mr chairman and the reason
i think it's of good design and as
councillor chan has said an improvement
okay thank you very much anyone else
wish to speak on that before we move
right we'll move to the vote berna
please
and we have taken all the reasons okay
so we have a good group
i'm going to just say yes
and um probably pre-empting my colleague
mr lee
there was a previous refusal for a
similar development
it is recognized that this scheme has
been substantially reduced
in terms of its balkan scale essentially
in terms of the gamble it is very
similar to the previous scheme
members need to be quite clear in terms
of their reasoning for supporting this
that the general principle
which we apply for ensuring that schemes
especially semi-detaches retain a
similar character
um would not be undermined in terms of
the proposal to support this scheme
so i think uh more clarity would be
required for members
thank you chad councillor channel could
you uh assist
council passenger please
um well i'm sure council passenger can
speak for himself but i
i have to say on this occasion i'm
afraid i can't agree with the officers
obviously that's why i've said i'm happy
to
second council basketball's proposal but
to me the design i
i think we can i can say that design um
is okay and the other and the other
policies that i named when i did the
calling i
i feel it doesn't go against those
policies chairman because well as we
know we have to define policies when we
call in
and i think actually uh mr john uh
mr johnson aware has said it this
application is not the same as that
previously refused
there have been tremendous changes and
members actually weren't involved in any
consideration of the previous
application to my knowledge i believe
that was done
under delegated powers so therefore
chairman this is the first time
as a member i feel i've had the
opportunity
um to look at this unless mr johnson
tells me i'm incorrect but i certainly
can't remember seeing this one come
through to committee before
and bearing in mind the degree of
reductions elsewhere
really the only one issue is this gamble
roof and having seen the plans tonight
on the screen
asked officers to present the
perspectives i wanted to see
i really do feel chairman that um it's
not worthy
of um my consideration to refuse it
and purely because i as we say design
is good design is important and i
fundamentally always fight for good
design chairman but this to me
does not actually fly in the face of
that
design uh policy in our ldp
council passenger did you want to come
back uh only mr chairman just to say
that
um the the this application has been
considerably
reduced in size so it is you know it has
fulfilled
one of the problems with the last
application i think good design is very
much
a consideration as we're always told so
i think
pretty much we we've covered it so
that's that's really it
berna did you uh as councillor boyce
want to come back and keep saying
flashing
he's not indicated in the meeting chat
but
now castle boys do you are you wishing
to speak on this
um no uh thank you chairman thank you
council boys i just saw your picture
flashing a bit so
i just wondered whether you did or
didn't
right we all finished then
can we now move to the vote barna please
to approve
thank you chairman so we're voting now
to approve the application contrary to
the officer's recommendation
i will i will take your name in
alphabetical order can you please
indicate clearly four against abstain
council of bassinger
ball that's the bill oh
is the bell full council boyce
against
four councillor helm
for cancer hull
four thank you members
that's six for the application one
against no abstentions
thank you chairman thank you very much
we need to
deal with conditions as well well i
think councillor channel and
council passenger did do that oh oh yeah
i think i'll give you something
sorry yeah yeah okay conditions please
well chairman we have the plans it would
be as per the plans and then obviously
materials everything else we normally do
on an
i would recommend that they are the
standard time
condition um approval of
you know plans as council changes said
the materials
i'd recommend that they're tied into the
conditions that have been recently
imposed on the recently approved scheme
um and double checking
any statutory consultants that may have
suggested anything and
showing that they meet the sixth test
thank you chairman are all members happy
with that
thank you mr chairman yes right
that's julie carried then any items of
business that the chairman of the
committee decides are urgent there are
none
now just before i go just say thank you
very much for putting up with me as
chairman
and i closed the meeting at 1834.
thank you very much everybody thank you
chairman thank you
thank you
everyone good night